I think the federal government's a lost
cause in trying to come by all everybody
and peace again is not going to happen
so I think that separation and people
going to places where people think the
same way they are is the ultimate
solution I mean at this point you know
when I see conservatives crying about
the Streets of San Francisco and like
how horrible it's become I'm just like I
don't take them seriously anymore it's
like why do you care about San Francisco
anymore it's so obviously toast and gone
or Chicago because they vote in our
federal elections which have an impact
on that weather exactly not protecting
our borders whether or not the
government is increasing the tax rate so
when you have California bringing in
non-citizens and using that to inflate
their census numbers so they get more
votes in Congress and intellectual
College we've got a very very serious
problem with what San Francisco is doing
yeah well that's that's the problem
right there that they have control over
us and the solution is trying to
decrease the control that these other
states have over us